Okay, it's been decided.
The 29th of may,
the very last Wednesday in may of 2024
will be the national and provincial elections.
Forget what Deputy President
Paul Macedela said about the 24th of may.
Forget that.
Forget what Rob Hershoff said.
It's not the 22nd of may,
it's the 29th of may.
What I love the most are the responses on Twitter.
Some people are saying the 29th of may is on you
27th of April.
We will be free from all of the above. How
I'll be walking in to cause my vote on the 29th of may.
I'll be marking my ex. For me,
this is one of my favourites.
It says 29th of May,
Sitiku a and C,
those of us that have registered to vote is over. Pyong,
May 29th and is our vote.
Let us exercise
our democratic right and vote for our future.
I'll see you there 29th of may. See you on.